HAS VOWED TO BRING THE BORDER
CRISIS TO THEIR FRONT DOOR.
LET'S BRING IN LAWRENCE JOHNS
HOST OF "CROSS-COUNTRY."
THE ILLINOIS GOVERNOR HAS
WELCOMED THESE MIGRANTS.
IS ERASEIST?
WOULD LORI LIGHTFOOT CALL HIS
RACIST?
THIS IS VOLUNTARY.
THE MIGRANTS WANT ON THE BUSES
AND TREATED WELL AS THEY GO UP
THERE HOUSED AND FED.
MOST OF THEM REPORTEDLY HAVE
PEOPLE WAITING FOR THEM WHEN
THEY GET TO THESE VARIOUS
CITIES TO HELP THEM OUT,
LAWRENCE.
YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> A COUPLE OF THINGS.
FOR YEARS WE'VE HEARD FROM THE
DEMOCRATS THAT THEY WANT TO BE
A SANCTUARY.
TEXAS HAS TAKEN ALL THEY CAN
TAKE.
WE AREN'T JUST TALKING ABOUT
THE REPUBLICANS.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THOSE
BORDER AREAS RUN BY DEMOCRATS
THAT SAY THAT WE HAVE TOTALLY
INUNDATED ALL OF OUR SOURCES.
THEY HAVE DRAINED ALL THE
SOURCES, THE FOOD, THE HOUSING
THERE, THE HOTELS.
AND SO NOW YOU ARE GIVING THE
DEMOCRATS WHAT THEY HAVE
ESSENTIALLY ASKED FOR.
IT IS NOT LIKE TEXAS IS
BRINGING THESE PEOPLE ACROSS
THE BORDER.
THEY'RE ALREADY HERE.
THEY'VE DRAINED ALL THE
RESOURCES AND THEY ARE GIVEN
THE DEMOCRATS WHAT THEY WANT.
NOW THE DEMOCRATS ARE SAYING
THE TEXANS AREN'T BEING
COMPASSIONATE?
WE'VE BEEN COMPASSIONATE FOR
YEARS BUT WE REACHED OUR
BREAKING POINT.
I CONTINUE TO BE PERPLEXED BY
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THIS POLICY OR THE PRESIDENT'S
SPEECH YESTERDAY GOING AFTER
THE MAGA PEOPLE.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REMIND THE AUDIENCE THE
SIGNATURE ISSUE OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, WHETHER YOU LIKE HIM
OR NOT.
PEOPLE ELECTED HIM IN 2016 ON
IMMIGRATION BEING THAT ISSUE.
THEN YOU GO AFTER THOSE PEOPLE
AND SAY THOSE MAGA REPUBLICANS
ARE RACIST AND PART OF THE
PROBLEM?
THEY'RE DESTROYING THE SOUL OF
THE COUNTRY?
JOE BIDEN, THOSE 2016 MAGA
REPUBLICANS VOTED FOR YOU IN
THE LAST ELECTION AND PART OF
THE REASON WHY YOU WON.
I DON'T KNOW IF THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES HAS BEEN
PROPERLY BRIEFED ON THE DATA OF
THE 2020 ELECTION.
BUT THEY DIDN'T VOTE FOR YOU
BECAUSE OF THE ISSUES WHEN IT
COMES TO IMMIGRATION OR ECONOMY.
56% OF AMERICANS ACCORDING TO
GALLUP SAID THEY WERE BETTER
OFF.
THEY VOTED FOR YOU ON ONE
ISSUE, TO BRING THE COUNTRY
TOGETHER AND LOWER THE TONE.
IF YOU CANNOT DO THAT, THEN YOU
ARE A WORTHLESS PRESIDENT.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DIDN'T VOTE
FOR YOU BASED ON THOSE ISSUES.
THEY VOTED FOR YOU BECAUSE OF
UNITY.
IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE HE IS
INTERESTED IN UNIFYING THE
COUNTRY.
>> Dana: LAWRENCE, I WAS
EXCITED TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT
THIS TODAY.
YOU LIVE IN TEXAS AND KNOW
TEXAS WELL BUT YOU ALSO KNOW
CHICAGO VERY WELL.
THE TEXAS GOVERNOR SAID THIS IN
RESPONSE TO LORI LIGHTFOOT.
MAYOR LIGHTFOOT LOVES TO TOUT
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF HER CITY
TO WELCOME ALL REGARDLESS OF
LEGAL STATUS AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO SEEING THIS RESPONSIBILITY
IN ACTION AS THEE MIGRANTS
RECEIVE RESOURCES FROM A
SANCTUARY CITY WITH A CAPACITY
TO SERVE THEM.
CALL FOR NUMBER TWO.
ALONG THE SOUTHERN BORDER
199,000 VERSUS D.C. 7400 AND
NEW YORK CITY 1500 AND CHICAGO
75.
THESE ARE THE ENCOUNTERS THAT
HAVE BEEN SEEN.
SO WHEN SHE SAYS THIS IS RACIST.
HELP ME UNDERSTAND.
IS THAT JUST A WORD SHE IS
THROWING AROUND OR WHAT DOES
SHE MEAN BY THAT?
>> RACISTS IS TELLING THE PRESS
CORPS THAT YOU'LL DO INTERVIEWS
WITH PEOPLE THAT ARE MINORITIES.
I CONTINUE TO BE DISGUSTED WITH
THIS MAYOR BECAUSE SHE HAS AN
INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY TO
ACTUALLY BRING PROGRESS.
SHE IS NOT JUST FAILING THE
UNITED STATES WHEN SHE SAYS I
WANT THE ILLEGALS AND WHEN THEY
COME SHE TURNED THEM AWAY.
SHE HAS FAILED THE SCHOOLS AND
CRIME.
I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN DOING
COMMUNICATIONS FOR A LONG TIME,
DANA.
THERE IS A MESSAGING PROBLEM
AND ALSO A POLICY PROBLEM WITH
THE DEMOCRATS.
THEY CONTINUE TO PROPOSE
SOLUTIONS BUT WHEN THEY HAVE TO
ACTUALLY DEAL WITH THE PROBLEMS
LIKE IMMIGRATION, THEY SAY I
DON'T WANT TO DEAL WITH IT.
THEY HAVE CONTINUED TO SAY
BRING ME ALL YOUR PEOPLE HERE.
COME, YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO BY
THE RULES.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THE PROPER CHANNELS FOR
IMMIGRATION.
GO THROUGH THE FILING PROCESS.
BUT WHEN THE PEOPLE COME HERE
THEY GET UPSET WHEN THE
GOVERNMENT SHIPS THEM TO THEIR
CITIES.
I JUST DON'T GET IT.
THE PRESIDENT COULD SAY LOOK, I
HAVE -- I WANT TO GET
IMMIGRATION REFORM DONE.
THAT WASN'T WHAT HIS SPEECH WAS
ABOUT.
IF THE DEMOCRATS -- IF THE
PRESIDENT, IT IS THESE MAYORS
THAT CONTINUE TO BE A
DISAPPOINTMENT TO ME, DANA.
>> Dana: YEAH.
LAWRENCE JONES, KNEW YOU WOULD
BE A GOOD GUEST ON THI